okay today I'm going to talk to you
about collision theory collision theory
is a way of explaining rates of reaction
based on how particles collide with each
other they bump into each other there's
four different things that we need to
know about to do with collision theory
so basically to begin with in order for
a chemical reaction to happen the
particles need to collide with enough
energy for a reaction to occur if they
don't collide no reactions can occur so
there's four things that we know that
influence this number one is temperature
so let's imagine we have these two
different types of particles which need
to react with each other okay so we're
reacting the blue particles with the red
ones here now if it's really cold these
particles are going to not going to have
much kinetic energy that's movement
energy so they're going to be moving
around slowly
this means that their collisions aren't
going to be very frequent so there's a
slow rate of reaction the more we heat
this up the faster these particles go
the more kinetic energy they have as a
result there will be more frequent
collisions and a faster rate of reaction
the second thing we need to know about
is concentration
so all concentration means is how many
particles we have within a particular
volume so let's imagine this right here
at the moment we have a relatively low
concentration of these particles meaning
there's not many of these particles
within this volume this means that
there's not going to be very frequent
collisions if we increase the
concentration so let's say we've got
loads more of these particles now
we can see because there's more of the
particles there's going to be more
frequent collisions therefore we're
going to have a faster rate of reaction
so the higher the concentration the
greater the rate of reaction now the
third thing we need to know about is
surface area so surface area let's
imagine that this is a little blog of
our reaction let's say if we drop this
and react it with some acid we can only
react on the external surfaces at any
one time so the surface area limits the
rate of reaction I'm going to use these
kind of sponges to demonstrate this idea
so imagine this was my reactant that I
was putting in some acid reacting with
some acid at the moment the acid can
only work and react with the external
surfaces so there's going to be a
limited rate of reaction if I was to
break this into smaller pieces we can
now see there's more surface available
for the acid to react on because by
breaking it apart we expose more surface
to react with so the greater the surface
area the faster the rate of reaction
because we have more surfaces that can
react at any one time the fourth and
final thing we need to know about our
catalyst so a catalyst is something
which speeds up the rate of reaction
without being used up itself and this is
how it works the surface of the catalyst
acts as a surface for our particular
reactants to react so rather than just
moving around they can actually react
upon the surface of the catalyst like
this
so as a result this cat this surface
this catalyst has provided a surface for
this reaction
notice how the catalyst isn't being used
up itself it's just providing the
surface for this reaction to occur so
those are the four different things we
need to know about collision theory the
greater the temperature the faster
particles moves so the there's more
collisions plus the rate of reaction the
higher the concentration the more
particles there are in the volume in
that volume the more collisions there
are the faster rate of reaction the
greater the surface area the greater the
rate of reaction and by having a
catalyst we provide a surface which also
speeds up the rate of reaction thank you
very much